a vontade pessoal eu sou um traidor do
sistema
muitos já pensam em buscar um nerd né
é bem que o neto está um pouco mais na
moda hoje em dia a gente além de falar
português e espanhol e inglês
a gente costuma falar também em algumas
línguas tipo vhp javascript e css
parece complicado mas é menos complicado
que grego ainda e essas mesmo jeito que
as línguas humanas não foram capazes de
criar países foram capazes de criar
sociedades nega virtuosas né
a língua de gualeguaychú de computador
ela tá certa forma nem fazendo todo esse
mundo aí fazendo toda essa ansiedade
criada pela língua humana
a gente hoje tem redes sociais é que a
população de um país inteiro de vários
países
esse tipo de redesenho da sociedade é
muito novo
mais ou menos só há 20 anos atrás a
gente ainda trocava mensagens assim
os vendedores de software é o co2 do
sistema estão mudando a maneira que a
gente ganha e que a gente perde dinheiro
estão mudando a maneira que a gente se
transporta ele está mudando a maneira
que a gente viaja seus pedra e até
criaram uma livraria do mundo né que a
amazon
claro que casa de ferreiro espeto de pau
então a tecnologia vai botar um pouco o
programador né
mas é uma fronteira de desenvolvedores
ainda não estão se atrevendo tanto né há
um certo gargalo nessa transformação
toda aqui a sociedade está passando é
muito comum tecnologia sejam taxados de
piratas
a gente ouviu isso a música tem ouvido
agora com a história do transporte
privado coletivo e essa barreira é a
fronteira final é política
a gente olha essa foto já senti até 1 e
é muito comum ouvir falar assim a um
problema no sistema ou então algum de
seus componentes na educação saúde e eu
acho que é verdade mesmo problema é o
sistema permanente olha essas coisas
assim se percebe que tem algo muito
errado que o sistema está muito
desregulamentada a esse é o recorde de
trânsito em são paulo quase 300
quilômetros mas tem imagens piores até
imagens como a gente vê acontecendo aí
nos jornais na tv todos os dias e esse
tipo de desregulação
a gente costuma chamar no também do
software é como um sistema incompleto
é quase como se a nossa democracia você
ainda uma tivesse na sua fase beta
isso quer dizer que ela tem alguns bugs
quer dizer que ela tem imperfeições a
gente precisa tratar
eu acabei de montar isso ou dez minutos
atrás usando a internet
eu não sabia dessa foto acabei deixando
e é isso né você está usando um sistema
que está fazendo um resultado
completamente diferente se esperava essa
é real ea gente tem outros efeitos desse
sistema desregulado né
pode ser a opção pode ser até mesmo a
burocracia que é uma das maiores
inimigas da inovação né tem coisa pior
para sabotar a criatividade do que a
burocracia como a gente trata esse tipo
de problema no sistema
a gente separa e trata ele caso a caso
não chamados bancos são tratados caso a
caso
lógico que faz uma grande análise sobre
isso pra entender se não vai afetar todo
o sistema
então pensando um pouco dessa maneira em
2008 comecei a pensar quais componentes
da democracia a gente poderia refazer ou
quais são os bancos estão aí infectando
esse sistema a gente pode tratar o
primeiro projeto que eu me envolvi chuva
eo voto distrital é uma campanha teve
início em 2008 mobilizou muitas pessoas
pela mudança do sistema eleitoral
nem sei se concordo mas com voto
distrital
mas foi muito importante em 2008 falar
sobre política eu lembro de ir a bares
na augusta em são paulo falar com as
pessoas sobre isso e muita gente virar a
cara acha que você já tem uma forma se
corrompendo está ligado a algum partido
não está filiado a nenhum partido
só queria conversar sobre o tema
eleitoral depois eu me envolvi com o
outro movimento que é o porto alegre
como vamos nesse movimento
ele qualificou as eleições municipais em
porto alegre
então a gente estou todos os candidatos
a vereador ea prefeito permitir que a
população pudesse escolher seus
candidatos
é uma maneira muito mais qualificada um
problema no projeto pelo menos um
programa de governo que muitos
vereadores
não fazem né depois disso um candidato
se interessou pelo trabalho que eu já
estava fazendo alguns movimentos né
ele pediu para fazer a campanha dele
tinha esse mote recife a política foi
muito divertido porque a gente pode
inovar tanto onde pode fazer por exemplo
essa lixeira enquanto os outros
candidatos não fazendo panfletos
a gente fez uma lixeira com a identidade
do candidato e com esse mote receita
política todo mundo pegar o conceito do
candidato x ela jogou na lixeira dele
era ótimo a gente trabalhando no centro
assim nossa como a gente é genial cinco
anos em um centro da cidade um monte de
gente pegando o prefeito elmano férrer
jogando lance é mais do que passar a
mensagem já convertida na hora em um
determinado momento a gente teve que é
fazer algum tipo de material assim
físico né
estava sendo muito as novas tecnologias
da web ea gente criou um panfleto em
papel semente
então as pessoas se entregaram ao
prefeito mas elas plantavam porque ele
completa também passava muita mensagem
depois é moto vereador convidou pra
fazer um gabinete digital pra ele né
além disso tem essa tradição não é tanto
com o orçamento participativo e até
mesmo com esse dado digitais e se
goleador foi muito inovador porque ele
deixou a o voto nas assembléias da
câmara à disposição dos leitores então
você entrava no site e você voltava por
ele uma maneira experimentar uma
democracia direta
até que em determinado momento é eu
entrei no sistema
neste momento ele faz um bom alerta é
isso né
o convite da prefeitura de são paulo
para fazer a revisão do plano diretor
estratégico da cidade
o plano diretor estratégico ele tem um
caráter mais urbana mas ele pode afetar
todo o rumo da cidade e eu sabia que
seria uma tarefa difícil já tinha algum
contato com a política mas não sabia que
é impossível praticamente esse tipo de
trabalho
ele van
nesse trabalho ele não depende claro de
uma pessoa só depende de uma equipe
inteira né
ele depende de conexão com a internet
ele depende de acesso às redes sociais
depende de uma série de coisas e quando
você chega na prefeitura tem que fazer
uma espécie de renascimento assim que
não têm acesso a nada
você vai pedindo permissão para todo
mundo para conseguir fazer alguma coisa
assim
estava esperando criar um ambiente mais
ou menos assim a prefeitura mas na
verdade o ambiente era mais tô aqui
baias né quadrados
os ambientes são muito estimulantes da
colaboração e para piorar ainda tinha um
prazo superar a perda de um mês pra
fazer pelo menos um site que anunciasse
essa
esse plano diretor para a cidade não
bastasse prazo a gente ainda tinha um
fantasma que era o fantasma da última do
último plano diretor tentou ser revisado
pelo prefeito anterior
o último plano diretor foi barrado na
justiça quem não teve participação
suficiente
a gente só conseguiu porque a gente
tinha todo o arcabouço todo o
conhecimento preservado em comunidades
online de software livre e sofre também
com o código aberto esse tipo de
tecnologia permite recombina soluções da
gente estude essas soluções que já foram
implementadas
enfim a gente tem uma velocidade muito
maior e economia que é importante é se
tratando de governo além do software
livre você precisa de habilidade está
recombinar para desenvolver só pela
gente vimos hoje o design e programação
de metodologias ágeis de gerenciamento
de projeto também com om estratégias
hagens e até mesmo a habilidade das
redes sociais
na época ainda não não tinha ocorrido a
jornada de junho amy estava claro pra
gente que a gente entra nas redes
sociais que está mais próximo da
população
essa é a cara da plataforma que a gente
criou não parece nada super inovador mas
feito dentro do governo é algo magno a
dor a gente conseguiu fazer com que todo
o conteúdo ficasse muito mais simples
muito mais fácil né com as leis ficaram
muito mais fácil ser acessadas
os mapas da cidade a gente conseguiu
abrir completamente permite design cs5
recombinar esses mapas estudar eles não
uma profundidade maior
afinal a gente tinha aqui atingir 12
milhões de pessoas mais ou menos né
porque são paulo quando e rio também é
quando a gente quando começa o dia tem
aquela invasão também né
então imagina quanta gente vive nessas
cidades mesmo imaginar dois milhões de
pessoas já tentou fazer uma estratégia
com cinco amigos é praticamente
impossível se você quiser com 20 30
tenta fazer com 12 milhões
então a gente usou e abusou também de
ferramentas participativas e
colaborativas que permitiam que essa
população não só enviar sua contribuição
mas também que ela pudesse acompanhar o
sol estava escrevendo até que é o
conhecimento fosses o mundo né
um exemplo muito legal é esse mapa
esse mapa ele provocou a população não é
sobre quais os problemas e soluções
a gente teve que se tem são paulo tem e
pra fazer esse mapa
a gente tem que desafiar muita gente
porque a visão comum é a ti vai abrir a
participação um mapa da cidade com botão
problema botão solução vai chover de
problemas vão avaliar a nova gestão vai
ganhar popularidade vão perder já começa
todo o circuito negativo gente desafiou
essa essa ordem praticamente em que o
simão é nossa surpresa foi muito não pra
surpresa de quem já conhecer as
tecnologias
para surpresa de quem estava mais
acostumado com a política pública teve
muito mais solução do problema
essa essa minuta que está à direita
ela é ela é uma espécie de espelho da
própria lei que foi depois da câmera
então censurada pelo prefeito um spoiler
já falei com a lei foi sancionada mas
também é muito legal porque essa
essa minuta online ela permitiu que por
exemplo o cara da construtora disse o
comentário do arquiteto que eles
conversassem não em audiência pública
que aquela gritaria que ela disputa pela
fala pela na verdade não um ambiente
muito mais pacífico que tinha um período
muito mais tranqüilo para a contribuição
que o cidadão ou o a qualquer
representante desse segmento pudesse
colaborar desde a noite de casa
tranquilo
quem tem tempo ainda uma audiência
pública hoje é muito difícil né
somente nos horários que geralmente elas
acontecem mas é claro esse processo eles
são importantes
então a gente não só fez essa parte
digital como também é contou com a sorte
de ter uma equipe muito preparada para
fazer a participação durante toda a
revisão do plano diretor
só que a gente pegou essa participação
que sim acontecer em audiências o
sinistro mais elevou também o nível do
software
então esse é um exemplo de um encontro
feito para as pessoas de baterem quais
funcionalidades deveria estar dentro do
software que cada funcionalidade é uma
decisão política também se eu tiro uma
funcionalidade por exemplo de enviar um
problema que já está afetando é
consideravelmente aquela participação
então a gente convidou também a
população para opinar no software e isso
continuou hoje é uma política da
controladoria do município
basicamente o que a gente fez com aquela
secretaria o que a gente fez com revisão
da lei onde fez com o projeto que depois
da lei é tornar ele escalava o repetível
que é praticamente mantém todas estatais
né
como nós criam essas grandes inovações
então isso permitiu que muita gente
desce contribuir sem aumentar muito os
nossos custos e permitir que usar o
ambiente digital
essa estrutura fosse repetido para cada
uma das participações que a gente vai
fazer
e foram várias com mais ou menos três
fases de participação
portanto em cinco meses
a gente conseguiu dois milhões de
acessos
é muito se você está falando de política
é muito está falando um plano diretor é
uma lei do marco regulatório urbano
então esse processo né acabou atraindo
muita atenção de movimentos mais
conservadores
esses movimentos tentaram assim como
fizeram com a outra lei barra
nessa nova mas ela não foi parado porque
a gente conseguiu sistematizar toda a
participação a gente conseguiu usar
todos os dados que estavam nas
ferramentas nessas tecnologias foram
criadas para provar que a participação
foi intensa
a gente tinha por exemplo álbum de fotos
de todas as todas as audiências todas as
oficinas um fácil acesso neste site
tudo estava muito e pronto pra ser
sistematizado dessa entregue caso
precisasse e quando você lida com a
população sem transparência e abertura
então é importantíssimo ter isso sempre
pronto
o prefeito assinou após um longo
processo também né de passagem pela cana
dois e eles são paulo já é conhecida
como uma cidade bem mais inovadora
hoje são paulo tem corredores de ônibus
em são paulo tem uma cidade mais humana
na cidade mais aberta
esse é esse trabalho todo e foi até
reconhecido pela onu habitat a onu
selecionou a revisão do plano diretor de
são paulo ea plataforma gestão urbana
como uma referência de design de
políticas como referência de governo
eletrônico também
apesar desse nome e mail também né
nesse estado o governo eletrônico é e
que aconteceu no fim o que eu posso
contribuir de certa forma para quem está
hoje na universidade é quem está
buscando fazer a diferença no mundo como
a gente está acho que fazendo um
pouquinho um sistema mudou o sistema
sistema está errado a gente pode
reprogramar o sistema está errado a
gente pode desenvolver um novo álbum que
não foram só os criativos e jovens que
entraram na prefeitura comigo aqui
fizeram a mudança mas sem nós ela
aconteceria
a gente espera alguma mudança das
pessoas que estão fazendo as mesmas
coisas há muito tempo a gente vai ficar
com medo não vai à anac lo porque ele
atinja todas as culturas tiveram algum
momento os livros escritos pelo povo
uma consulta ao povo caso fosse mudar
suas regras
as idéias de eleições audiências
isso é mas o que dá conta do processo
democrático
a gente precisa fazer é criar um sistema
novo
vamos resolver essa nova democracia
gente ligada
[Aplausos]